As
we wasted a lot of time at school
learning spelling,
the kids continue to waste a lot of time
at school with spelling,
so I want to share with you
a question. Is there a need for a new
spelling
?
we already have and the question and the answer
are new in our language, they
have been bouncing from century to century
for a long time since in 1492, in
the first grammar of the Spanish language,
Antonio de Nebrija established
a clear and simple principle for our orthography,
thus we have  write as
we pronounce and pronounce as
we write each sound should
correspond to a letter each letter
should represent a single sound and those
that will not represent any sound should be
eliminated
this criterion the phonetic criterion
which says that we have to write
as we pronounce to be and it is not in the  The
basis of the spelling as
we practice it today is because Spanish,
unlike other languages ​​such as
English or French, always had a
strong resistance to writing too
differently from how we pronounce it, but
it is not because when in the 18th century it was
decided how we were going to standardize  our
writing
there was another criterion that gave a good part
of the decisions
that other criterion was legitimate logical the one
that says that we have to write
according to how the words will be written in
their original language in latin greek and so
we stay with hache judas we write
but we pronounce ourselves like this  we were left
with long b and short b which,
contrary to what many people believe,
never differed in
pronunciation from Spanish,
thus we were left with g,
sometimes they sound outskirts like in people and
sometimes they sound soft like y datos, so we
were left with cesc feces and zetas  three
letters that in some places
correspond to a sound and in other
places but none to three I am
not here to tell you anything that you do not
know from personal experience
all of us went to school all
of us invested large amounts
of time learning large
amounts of that time  of
children's plastic brain invited in the
memorization of spelling rules
full of exceptions, however, transmitted to us
in many
implicit and explicit ways
the idea that
something fundamental to our training was at stake in spelling;
however, I have the feeling that
the teachers either  They asked why it
was so important and they even asked themselves
a previous question, what was the function
of spelling, what is
spelling for, and when
one asks that question, the answer is
much simpler and less
important than what they usually  believing
spelling serves to standardize
writing so that we all write
the same and therefore it is not easier
to understand each other when we read but in
contrast to other aspects of the
language such as punctuation, for example, in
spelling there is no
individual expressive ability involved in  the
punctuation yes, with the punctuation I can
choose to change the meaning of a sentence
with the punctuation it could print a
particular rhythm what I am writing with
the spelling not with the spelling or
it is good or it is bad depending on whether
or not it conforms to the
norms
but then it would not be more sensible
to simplify the current norms so that
it is easier to teach to
see and correctly use
spelling, it would not be more sensible
to simplify the current norms so that
all that time that we dedicate today to
teaching spelling that would
we can dedicate to other issues of the
language whose complexity is worth the
time and effort what I propose
is not to abolish orthography, it is that
everyone writes as they want
the language is a tool for
common use and therefore it seems
fundamental to me that  We use it following
common criteria, but it also seems
essential to me that these common criteria
are as simple as possible,
especially because we simplify our
spelling, we are not leveling
down when the spelling is simplified,
the quality of the language is not recent at all,
I work for everyone.  the days with the
literature of the golden age i read
garcilazo cervantes góngora quevedo
sometimes they write man without h
sometimes they write write with a short be and it
is absolutely clear to me that the
difference between those texts and
ours is one of convention or lack of
convention still in their time
but not of quality but let me go back to
the teachers because they are key characters
in this story I mentioned a while ago
that somewhat reflective insistence with
which the teachers crush us and
crush us with spelling but the
truth is  Things being the way
they are,
this makes total sense in our
society,
spelling works as a
privileged index that allows us to distinguish the
cult from the brute, the educator from the
ignorant, regardless of the
content of what is being written,
one can get or stop getting
a job for  an h
was put or not put one can
become the object of public ridicule
for once misplaced
so in that clear context it makes
sense to spend all that time
spelling but we must not forget that
throughout the history of our
language  It was always teachers or
individuals linked to the teaching
of the first letters who
promoted spelling reforms, who
realized that sometimes our spelling
was an obstacle to the
transmission of knowledge in our
case, for example, Sarmiento together with
Andrés Bello promoted the greatest reform.
orthography that has actually taken
place in the Spanish language, which was that
of Chile in the mid-19th century.
Why then, to take over from
those teachers, start advancing
our Soca orthography in the privacy
of the other 10,000, I would like to put
some on the table  Modifications that
seem reasonable to me to start discussing,
let's eliminate laxe muta where
we write an h
but we don't say anything, don't write
anything.
Before they were never distinguished in the
Spanish language,
let's choose one, it can be anyone, we
can discuss, sit down, each one will
have their preferences, each
one can argue, we want not
with one, let's eliminate the other, g and j,
let's divide the functions so that
the soft sound remains for people, cats, magician, aila,
and that  la jota challenged the harsh sound
arabic giraffe argentinian people and s
iceta is an interesting case because
it shows that the phonetic criterion must
be a villa but it cannot be an
absolute principle in some
data the differences in pronunciation
must
now be addressed as I said before cs iceta  In some
places they correspond to one sound, in
others to two, and from three letters we go down to
two. We
are all better off. To some,
these changes may seem a bit
drastic, but they are not so drastic.
it must be
modified that the language is linked
to history, traditions and
customs but that it is also a
practical tool for daily use and
that sometimes this attachment to history,
traditions and customs
becomes an obstacle for today's use
In fact, this explains that our language,
much more than the ones we know than the
ones we have geographically close to us, has
historically changed in us.
For example, we went from spelling to
spelling, we went from theater to theater, we
went from quantity to quantity, we went
'symbol by symbol and little by little now.
some hashes are beginning to withdraw quietly fashions in the dictionary
of the royal academy harp harmony can be
registered with ac or without ah and we are
all fine it also seems to me that
this is a particularly
appropriate moment to face this discussion we are
always told that the language  it changes
spontaneously from the bottom up that it
is the users who incorporate
new words
who introduce
grammatical modifications and that the authority in
some places an academy in other
places a dictionary in other places
a ministry
long after accepts them in
incorporates this is true only  for
some levels of the language it is true
for the lexical level for the
word level it is less true for the
grammatical level and I would almost say that it is not
true for the orthography level
which historically always changed from
top to bottom were always the
institutions that set the rules
and proposed modifications because I'm
just saying that this is a
particularly appropriate moment
until today writing has always had a
much more restricted and private use than
speech but our time the age of
social networks
that is undergoing a
revolutionary change  Never before has so much been written
as now, never before have so many written
so much in the sight of so many and in these
social networks for the first time we are
seeing novel spelling uses on a large scale
where even people with
impeccable spelling and but educated
when they write on social networks
behave quite similar to  how
most users of
social networks behave, that is, they relax
spell checking and prioritize
speed and efficiency in
communication
for now there are chaotic
individual uses but it seems to me that we have to
pay attention to it because it is
probably not being said that
An age that assigns writing
a new place is asking for
new criteria for that writing.
I think we would be wrong to reject them
because we identify them
as a symptom of the cultural decadence
of our time. I don't think we should
observe them, order them, and prosecute them
within  a regulation more in tune with the
needs of our times
I can anticipate some objections
there will be those who say that if we simplify
the spelling
we are going to lose the etymology
in rigor if we wanted to preserve the
etymology it would not be enough with the
spelling
also we should learn Latin Greek
Arabic with a simplified spelling
come on  to go to recover the etymology to the
same place where we are going now to the
etymological dictionaries a second
objection will be that of those who say if we
simplify the spelling we will
stop distinguishing ib3 and words that
today differ by only one letter that
is true  but it's not a problem
our language has homonyms it has
words with more than one meaning and we get
confused the bank where we sit
the bank where we deposit the money
the suit we wear of the things
we brought in the vast majority of
situations
the context dissipates  any confusion,
but there is a third objection for me, the
most understandable, even the most
moving, which is what they say I
don't want to change that I was brought up like this the
custom in this way when I read a
word written in simplified spelling my
eyes hurt that objection  It
is partly within each one of us that
I believe that we must do it
as it is always done in these
cases the changes are made forwards
the boys are taught the
new rules those of us who do not want to are allowed to
write as we are used to  And it is
expected that in the following time,
the new norms, the success of any
orthographic reform that touches
such deep-rooted habits, prudence,
consensus, gradualism and tolerance,
but we cannot let the
attachment to the festivals, customs,
prevent us from moving forward,
the best tribute that  What we can do to the
past is to improve
what we receive, so I think we
have to agree that the
academies have to agree
and clean up from our spelling
all those habits that we use because
we receive them even if they do not serve us,
I am convinced that they do  we do
that in the modest but
very important field of language,
we are going to be leaving the next
generations a better future or
[Applause]
and